what if you wanted to take a survey to
know which is the most popular spot in
your region of course you cannot ask
everyone so you decide to ask 30 people
in your region you have classified your
survey into 4 categories 3 of the most
popular cricket football tennis and all
others on the other sports so the first
person you meet says he likes football
so you write a 1 here
the next person says she likes tennis so
you write a 1 next to tennis the next
person says football so you write a 2
here we want to count how many people
fall into each category so out of 3
people surveyed to like football and one
person likes tennis the next guy says
cricket so you write a 1 here the next
guy also says cricket so you write a 2
here so out of the 5 people surveyed do
like cricket - like football and one
likes tennis then someone else has
baseball and then someone else says
football what do you notice it gets a
bit tedious and is not the best way to
take a survey let's understand a better
way to do this try to understand this
really well when the first guy says
football you just put a small vertical
line next to football no numbers no
order nothing the next guy says tennis
so we just put a vertical line next to
tennis then the next guy says football
again we just draw a vertical line next
to the first vertical line notice that
in this case we just don't have to think
what the previous number was we just
draw a line when a person names his
favorite spot the next two guys say
cricket so we put two vertical lines
next to cricket and the list goes on so
until now
two people have said cricket four people
have said football two people have said
tennis and one person like some other
spot now
we come to the most crucial point of
this exercise when the next guy says
football as he will be the fifth person
to say so we strike out the first four
vertical lines so this symbolizes five
people but why a slanted line why can't
we just draw vertical lines imagine
counting the number of people if we did
something like this it will get really
difficult and that is why as a norm
every fifth count will cross out the
previous four counts let me erase this
so after asking all three people this is
how a final table will look like these
are called tally marks we can write down
the final numbers in the next column the
first row has five and five the number
will be five plus five which equals ten
the second row has five five and three
the total will be five plus five plus
three which equals thirteen so ten
people like cricket and thirteen like
football in the same way we can say that
two people like tennis and five like
other sports
you